longest end credits ever this game
Batman Arkham origins that's right I
still review games that just take a long
time to beat dude so Batman Arkham
origins is the prequel to the batman
arkham games you know Arkham Asylum and
Arkham City and it's done by a different
studio which made me go what should I
look forward to this did I played the
demo at PAX and the gameplay was
everything I remember Arkham City beings
all like okay yeah cool let's let's do
this and in Arkham origins Batman's
clocked in a couple years of being
Batman Bruce Wayne's a lot younger Jim
Gordon isn't the Commissioner yet but
now black mask has put a hit out on
Batman's head so now all these assassins
have come to Gotham and they're gonna
try to take Batman out now and then the
Joker comes to Gotham and he's gonna
raise a bit of havoc basically the start
of everything great we know about Gotham
City its Arkham origins or it should be
Gotham origins but then you wouldn't
have Arkham in the title and then we
just wouldn't know what the game is now
I had a lot of fun this game I'm not
gonna lie I locked into this game for
days I was just playing it ours would go
by and I'm alike
first of all story wise in terms of the
story this story is actually really
awesome it's a great story it's well
acted by the voice actors in this game
you get the feeling that Bruce Wayne
when he was Batman he's like I wanted to
take out thugs thieves criminals this is
a different game entirely all these
comic-book assassins have come to Gotham
City and the Joker comes to Gotham City
and he's just like I wasn't prepared for
this a couple scenes you can tell it's
really messing with his head and that
was really cool to see a couple of
things that people are white-knuckling
about this game is won Kevin Conroy is
not the voice of Batman he played the
voice of Batman in all the Arkham games
Batman the Animated Series this dude has
been the voice of Batman for twenty
years he's been the voice of Batman
about as long as Mark Hamill was the
voice of the Joker and Mark Hamill is
not the voice of the Joker in this game
Troy Baker is the voice of the Joker
right you know me I am literally the
biggest Joker fan I have ever met in my
life Troy Baker killed it as the Joker I
loved his mannerisms you can tell he is
the Arkham City Joker just a lot younger
the Joker in his Genesis he's like right
I'm on the scene now I'm gonna raise a
little bit of Cain here 2013 is
undeniably the year of Troy Baker Troy
Baker was the voice of Booker DeWitt and
BioShock Infinite he was the voice of
Joel in the Last of Us and now he's the
voice of the Joker and Arkham
Virgen this dude is established in terms
of voice actors and games for me it goes
David Hayter Nolan North Troy Baker
these three they're the trifecta the
Trinity of voice actors and games
consciously you know it's not Mark
Hamill and you do miss him but this
joker in here I'm telling you is the
young Joker from the Arkham game Troy
Baker great job as the Joker the voice
of Batman awesome his Batman he sounds
like a young Kevin Conroy Batman but
he's young in every sense of the word it
is Arkham origins you see things like oh
that's going to become this thing later
that's really cool it's just the genesis
of it now so many of those things in
here you can't help but just a fanboy
out right gameplay wise gameplay wise
generally speaking this game is what you
remember Batman Arkham City being
generally speaking you have your combos
counters you upgrade your tech it is
familiar game playing in that you wish
they did more with it but the
alternative is they change up the
gameplay entirely it doesn't even
resemble Arkham City anymore
in which case that to me would be worse
I'd rather they keep it very similar and
familiar to the Arkham game structure
rather than change it up entirely and
have it not resemble it at all however
you can't deny the fact that they do
less with it in this game and don't try
to pass it off as story wise like well
is the genesis of it so things aren't
gonna be as hard as they will be in
Arkham City now that's just lazy the
fact is the developers of the game
didn't push it the extra mile a lot of
the tech you get is like a lot of the
tech you got in Arkham Asylum and Arkham
City you know Arkham City you got that
ice grenade and this one you get a glue
grenade it does everything the ice
grenade does no different at all and so
you're like oh alright I got that piece
of tech I already had in the other game
it doesn't feel like there's a lot of
variety there my biggest complaint about
the game is how easy all the extras are
yeah this game gives you a fun load of
things to go search out you got to go
solve crimes you got to find these
enigma packs it's not really a spoiler
telling you there enigma packs so one of
the first things that happens in this
game is Batman has dialogue with this
guy through the computer named enigma
you know who that's gonna be
which is one of the really cool things
you like oh dude yeah I know that's
awesome you gotta go around and find
these data packs instead of Riddler
trophies their data packs in this game
now Arkham City made you work for that
some of them you just want to throw
your controller down and be like nope
done Arkham origins you find the pack
and if you have the tech to get it
you're going to get it I feel them were
hard to find admittedly a few of them
you had to be
all right how do I okay it's like this
but none of them made me rage quitter be
like no no none of it was like that you
find the pack if you have the device to
unlock whatever you're going to get it
in that moment they're really not that
hard to find it was kind of a bummer hey
I like Macs in a game out as much as
anyone else but I like feeling like I've
earned it when games just give it to you
is a bit of a bummer doesn't change the
fact that I spent hours upon hours of
fun time chasing down these data packs
and I was perfectly content doing it but
does the difficulty in that hold a
challenge to the Arkham City trophies
not at all
and travel you know you have the grapple
and you'd spam the X button he just
flies over rooftops is something that
you earn in Arkham City and this one
it's like you don't have to earn it
again we get it you know how to do it
which I actually like I like the fact of
the games like we know that you have
done that mechanic here it is right out
the gate
however in Arkham City you feel like it
was easier to grapple on to a lot of
different surfaces so many times in this
game I was flying by services I'm trying
to push r1 I'm like why can't I grapple
to that thing in front of me I'm telling
you gliding across the bridge is the
most annoying thing ever because you see
all these wires and cables and signs and
ledges all of it you know the bad
grapples should be able to grapple on to
you but in the end there's like not that
light post down there you can grapple on
to that you feel like you're starving to
death and you're going by and there's
like all-you-can-eat buffets right
beside you everyone just eaten like Oh
Frogger just waving at you you're like
bleep but why can't I get that the
grappling seemed a lot more limited in
this game and it was really annoying
because I like the feeling of just I'm
Batman I can grapple to a Ledge no
matter what unless it has barbed wire on
it other than that and there were a
couple of glitches in the game the first
cutscene I ran into the game was just
lagging I think it's cuz it was trying
to load while the cutscene was doing it
was like the ps3 was like no not having
it and from what I've read that's not an
issue with my ps3 everyone's Arkham
origins game did that that's a bummer
they should release the game when it's
done and free of those kind of bugs
especially when it's the first cutscene
there's no second first impression I'll
touch in the multiplayer but for me
multiplayer doesn't make a game I almost
don't want to talk about it because it's
not why I buy games ID I literally buy
games for the single-player campaign
however multiplayer it was fun it was
multiplayer at this point you have seen
every version of multiplayer that exists
you know
has the same structure as a lot of other
multiplayer games just with Batman
characters in that it is really cool
being Batman and taking down guys
they're doing stealth takedowns you're
hanging them from gargoyles and you've
know that these are players these are
not NPCs in that that's actually really
cool you know some kid on the other end
of the screen look oh just raging out
that that does make you feel like a
badass I'm not gonna lie but when you're
one of the thugs it's pretty fun of its
standard you know take the base hold off
the guys kill everyone else avoid the
Batman but aside from the fact that
Arkham origins doesn't really offer a
lot in terms of new gameplay and the
extras and secrets are really easy to
figure out Arkham origins was a lot of
fun to play it had a really cool story
if you're a Batman fan you got to pick
it up if you're a fan of the Arkham
games you really should pick it up and
I'm going to get a perfect score but
it's going to get a great score I will
say Arkham origins is worth buying at
full price it's hard to get me to lock
into a game and not move the last time I
binge like that was peace Walker
yeah I played it I'll do a video on it
before Metal Gear Solid 5 or so Batman
Arkham origins have you played it what
did you think about whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you